the Internet is a great place to find
out all the facts about your favorite
celebrities unless of course that
celebrity is Chuck Norris for Chuck
Norris fans the Internet is a minefield
of lies jokes and memes when the
boogeyman goes to sleep every night
the Texas closet for Chuck Norris so how
do you sort the real from the fake keep
watching to learn some things you didn't
know about Chuck Norris military man
Chuck Norris is a famous guy for playing
badass military men but that isn't all
Hollywood movie magic in fact Norris did
actually serve in the military joining
the Air Force at age 18 his four-year
stint proved to be life-changing while
serving at the Osan Air Base in South
Korea
Norris took his first martial arts
lessons in Tung pseudo the rest like so
many of chucks big-screen bad guys is
history
[Music]
Carlos Norris Nourse has played a lot of
roles over the course of his career but
one role you may not be familiar with is
Carlos Norris in his autobiography
against all odds my story Norris
revealed that he got the nickname of
Chuck while serving in the Air Force in
South Korea but he was born with the
name Carlos in honor of his dad's
minister it doesn't quite have the same
ring does it for Carlos on the other
hand his brother Weiland was named after
a beer so maybe Chuck got off easy
Brotherly dedication Norris's most
famous film role is Colonel James
Braddock the former prisoner of war who
returns to Vietnam to save his captive
comrades in missing in action and its
sequels
that story was very personal for Norris
as his younger brother Whelan Norris was
killed in Vietnam in 1970 chuckling I
wrote that Weiland met his end while
leading his squad through dangerous
enemy territory he had spotted an enemy
patrol laying a trap and was trying to
warn his men when the Vietcong cut him
down Norris dedicated missing-in-action
to his brother's memory karate world
champ following his honorable discharge
from the military Norris opened a karate
school in the US and started
participating in national competitions
people might forget now but he started
as a legitimate karate master by the end
of the 1960's he had risen to become the
middleweight professional karate
champion of the world
he caught the attention of stars like
Bruce Lee and Steve McQueen who
encouraged him to go into acting Norris
was inducted into the International
karate and kickboxing Hall of Fame
and in his own words he became the first
man ever in the Western Hemisphere to be
awarded an eighth degree black belt
grand master recognition in the
Taekwondo system something that still
humbles me to the core of my being
Saturday mornings superhero by the
mid-80s Norris had become a household
name so he parlayed that notoriety into
his own cartoon and comic books Chuck
Norris karate commandos premiered in
1986 and tanked only after five episodes
Chuck Norris with his team pepper too
much Teemo the samurai warrior we
Chuck's teenager predator but that was
still enough for Marvel Comics to put
out an adaptation of the series the
comic focused more on Chuck himself
which unfortunately wasn't a recipe for
success either the publisher pulled the
plug after just four issues and the
action figures Chuck Norris karate
[Music]
separately not worth much today what was
wrong with kids in the 80s speedboat
racer when he's not saving the world and
avenging evil Chuck Norris has another
passion racing speedboats in the late
80s Norris got into the high powered and
highly dangerous sport alongside fellow
action stars Kurt Russell and Don
Johnson why did he enjoy racing
speedboats he told people quote I do it
for kicks and right now
I'm looking forward to kicking some butt
campaign trail my plan is secure the
border
two words Chuck Norris in 2007 Norris
began a new role as a blogger and
political activist appearing alongside
Republican presidential candidate Mike
Huckabee at major events it didn't
actually help Huckabee win anything but
that hasn't deterred Norris who
continued to campaign for Huckabee
during the subsequent presidential
election cycle now one of the Chuck
Norris facts is that America is not a
democracy
it's a Chuck tater ship thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know what you've heard about
Chuck Norris
[Music]